life hacks 111 111 life just to recap
you more trampoline yes like a if you
imagine a big trampoline it's a little
smaller one yes and you're going to
that's gonna be your thing I am doing
that bounce happy yeah okay what is
funny condoms across them and
stethoscope
you should brought me and Johnny for
Christmas a one our beautiful brass and
glass and our Gus I think for brand
slices laugh yeah would it be for your
eyes the chips - it's on tables in front
grass and glass
ladies and gentlemen welcome back Joanie
and Youssef in the building welcome back
gentlemen
how you doing hello very good very good
life hacks 111 so what it is 1 111 my
foxes that's a lie we started on 101 and
Johnny you've actually got some four I
do I've done some preparation but don't
you dare I'm not going to do that why
I'm going to do though if you know what
their bowels are they are a protein
shake premade protein shake absolutely
fantastic taste lovely partnered with
the company from NACO and you can win a
crate of them all that you need to do is
share this episode to tag me in the
share actress relax wherever you follow
me I share this episode up and I'll
choose someone in December que sabemos
out to you and my first life hack is can
I see a question first
yeah but they're not protein bars they
also make milkshakes don't they yeah
I've got some an unarticulated yeah yeah
so my first life hack is replace milk on
cereal with bear bells white chocolate
okay I'm on board of that you might have
a lot of cereal you have a lot of sea 20
grams 20 grams of protein easy added on
to whatever you see realize for the day
we're gonna have to make it mine I'll
just give you one I'll just give you one
you can't take my life huh no no just
the type of cereal okay so granola works
very well with granola like white
chocolate babbles milkshake prochik
granola unbelievable zeroes are
fantastic so Thai calorie slightly
higher cost
I imagine much higher cost low yet but
must be tasty
i it's so good what's all chronology huh
don't ask him this question because it
only really get excited what's awkward
Hollywood you go mine's Asda own brand
yes special no okay so you're in for it
are we talking like granola with with
raisins raisins and nuts okay kill you
so I have kill yourself a Quaker granola
the Quaker raisin granola
is frankly lethal like you don't realize
it but if you could easily do the box
without yes so calorie dense fried
cereal isn't like some ways made cereal
really really tasty Chris is like some
calories really one nice supper before
we go to bed but Oh 20 grams of protein
down for the day yeah [ __ ] they go I do
think cereals a brilliant evening food
so really an evening it's it's the book
end of the day isn't it
I mean it's living in here Oh shove this
morning cereal before bed to cereal do
you eat cereal for breakfast I'm fasting
until about 1:00 p.m. usually so if I
would have cereal for breakfast in just
take the edge off for it just yes
dropping what like just mark sharpen our
focus you know it's bedtime blogging the
pencil but if it's like before bed you
actually have a list of life hacks
Johnny go tell us tell us the list so
the first one you weren't agree with
Chris okay so I know you think this
whole thing's a bit silly but a
SodaStream you got this for Christmas
right did it's a present
it is so fizzy water sparkling water is
when you add it up quite expensive and
also a faff if you either going to buy a
lot of sparkling water go on how is
buying sparkling water more of a faff
than having to make the [ __ ] that stuff
yourself because it's it's easy to make
it so you under the tap button done what
Johnny likes about litres but the more
he can shout the flavor of the water in
the room and then it's the same as that
the stuff that summer Alec Roy yeah so
save it that's the best descriptive I
tell you that yeah so I read that
description about Lacroix in its perfect
where is it while you drinking it it's
as if someone someone shouts like like
next door and that's that's the amount
of flavor in there isn't
but it's great for appetite expression
so if you're fasting and if you're not
like these sitting you have to count
your calories in order to lose weight or
manage your body weight then having
sparkling water instead of normal water
um carbonate drinks great for appetite
suppression it's also really nice so you
can I not why not die cup oh like green
tea caffeine and tastes awful okay but
why not Diet Sprite sprite zero
nobody's taste breath I'm just trying to
you know so it so once you've got a
SodaStream you need to have the gas
canister but they you can take them to
Lakeland get them swapped for another
one
where's Lakeland I like saying where's
WH Smiths I've never seen the word
Lakeland written once before seriously
never seen it written before that's cuz
you don't operate in like everything's
hard cash and nightclubs in the GTA map
just like blank great where you can buy
the guns and the one we can change the
color of your car and then in between
that is Lakeland just Lakeland unless
it's by City
oh here's the garages PSO so scream come
on I like it and they do little that you
can actually ironically turn it into
coke with a Lakeland yeah if you got the
different flavoring of what's the best
flavor
lemon lemon Diet lemon don't get for
God's sake don't get the ginger beer
don't get sucked into the organic stuff
because you go and there are some that
are in like brown like medicine we got
green are really nice they're a bit more
expensive and then you realize that the
the amount they have to dilute it by
you'd be better off just drinking like
red coke like the sugars insane was he
ever having like a nice zero calorie
beverage chill in the morning lovely to
I've made my own sugar drink I've gone
to effort an expense to make my own
third route ever graduate isn't as nice
of them
have you are you filtering the water
before so is it filtered water yes yeah
okay no that's not that's just because
you have scared me to death about Easter
and I feel like filtering it's like it's
not they're probably going to do
anything really built I least feel like
I'm doing something about it you need to
avoid whatever it is huh
ferret Asst irons or whatever it was
it's receipts I can't wash my hair I
can't like touch certain people or
certain people yes I'll show um no
candles are allowed yeah yeah anyway to
be honest johnny has actually taken the
highest yield estrogen things to avoid
which is microwaving Tupperware and stop
doing on which I'm so pleased with
because like when you're microwaving a
plastic container of food and then it's
all Wibbly then you just fine oh gee you
still get meal prep oh no no so I'm
taking myself now maybe three months Wow
interesting
very good before I forget just while we
were on the granola thing if you follow
us on Instagram you'll you'll know that
I have got a clinical addiction problem
to osdas best hazelnut dark chocolate
cherry granola absolutely on another
level like and that the problem is I get
how's the delivery and I get anxious
when there's less than three bags in the
house so I've always got maybe ten bags
of it at one time they're quite small
bags 500 gram finest arranged isn't it
so like that look at things in a single
soul doesn't it yeah and all of this
would only have a sprinkling maybe yeah
I think but use good it likes a good day
they're like 750 or about 750 April of
your diet is I'm telling you add bear
bells white chocolate on top of that and
it will be too much to hunt it'll be
enough that should probably be on admire
made up VIP
[Music]
cereal if you have a granola problem but
still don't gain weight is insane to me
so actually that's my next life hack I
may as well bundle it in but like since
we're talking of like how and this is
just because some of us Oh
weight gravitates but up or down
depending on our disposition and I've
noticed this a lot with a lot of the new
doctors starting that you see people's
weight distinctly go like up or down
depending on right there how busy there
were like what their coping strategy is
I suppose so like right
do you overwork or operate yeah exactly
so I'm like you ever Grover I overcome I
yeah my weight tanks so I've dropped
like four or five kilos over a few weeks
just with busy periods so granola and
just putting grated cheese on everything
is real life hack your life hack is how
to not lose weight in a stress eat I'm
so a lot of a lot of the life hacks I've
got today are you've got to pick the
direction because depending on which way
this is like one of those choose your
own destiny adventure yeah you want to
fight the dragon or do you want to run
right I realize that I've seen there's
only ever one right answer I suppose
about the beginning yeah but regardless
of your goal the hazelnut cherry dark
chocolate granola mind-blowing but it is
IT inducing when you get less than three
bags and what's the other thing
theater a to choose grated cheese on
everything but with the granola if you
get asked to delivery and you allow
substitutions they'll always try and
give you some bullsháá corners like
there's just nothing because if they
help they also have like an extra
special salted caramel crunch sounds
great terribly but it's just nothing in
comparison sometimes you're the guy will
have left and your own packing only
Stephanie ah I've been done like he
slipped in and he's taken the cherry
granola for himself
yeah so annoying okay next up so if you
are going on holiday I advise the e pack
a small drawstring bag so if you
remember about the size of an a three
piece of paper to a four bit paper
side-by-side saying the sort of thing
you'd have taken to the swimming baths
as a kid you Jamie I know zone I can
drawstring backpack and Reebok make one
which has got a single zip pocket across
the front of it and that's it it's just
a drawstring bag and it is the single
best thing that I've ever taken two for
going away with you've got your big
backpack that's probably
maybe got laptop electronics sunglasses
other stuff like towel and things I've
never even tell that's the event then
you've got suitcase that's and this is
even if you just go for a weekend but
you need I'm quickly going to the beach
I want to throw my towels
swim shorts sunglasses in kindle into
something and it's just that and you can
fold it up inside of another bag fully
behind that yeah is so good and I forgot
it when I went to on one of the trips
this year I forgot the bag and the the
holiday was essentially pointless pretty
inconvenient yeah but every I was a the
difficulty levels just been increased by
at least 50% of everything that's of
like take the big bag take my big bag
but passport in there no so I have
travel safe which was a small oval
lockable foam interior thing yeah that
then has a chain I get kind of like a
plastic of a chain that comes off and he
can hook that round something that was
when I was traveling and I didn't know
if it was going to be safe since in the
hotel that's a great idea that tink
would that should be the life hack
but both both of them no see I get
anxiety with me leaving it somewhere
leaving it in a hotel room you can't
can't flick your laptop in there really
can you in the safe
in the bag no no no you either can
you'll take your backpack with you I
imagine I just take everywhere they have
I leave the laptop in the hotel room
dear yeah but it's okay seats your
brother's apartment are ones I mean
you're never gonna be able to get a big
15 of 13 inch laptop into one of those
safes anyway they like I suppose it mmm
that's true but the other benefit of
that little backpack is if it's hot
which it probably is if you're on
holiday having a sweaty back where your
backpacks just like pressed against you
but super light little feeling man
honestly it is so fantastic to have that
and you've just got all little things
you can have you change you know just
throw your change in there when you've
done being good shopping places just
[ __ ] around amazing yeah Johnny I'm
just getting the exact name cuz I think
I've written exact name down
away it's a specific brand is that we go
out with this it's a so I have written
it down wrong
how's it shaver Wow so I'd written
natural grass but it's actually amazing
grass amazing ground mazing grass greens
powder
so the real ROI I've tried that the one
you gave me
yeah the chocolate one yeah yeah so they
make one where has cocoa in it and so I
heard this concept that I think I so
this is a separate lifehack which is if
you're buying flavored things get
chocolate flavor because chocolate
flavor is very easy to naturally flavor
with cocoa so when you get a chocolate
flavor something it typically tastes
pretty authentic you get strawberry
banana vanilla whatever I've learned
after tasting it off loving you you're
getting zero you are so off piste with
flavor in its well I've got ten kilos
still - well the other half of the ten
kilos to go third trick pina colada
pina colada but birthday cake never
again not that was terrible this isn't
five kilos of pinochle yeah I'm gonna
take you as a pina colada
yeah I'm just halfway through but the
birthday cake it's a bit salty it's like
eating salty dough with hundred actual
hundreds and thousands in the way who
was that in the protein shake someone
who honours birthday cake way but yes so
they do a they do a Coco I catch Auklet
flavor greens powder they're all it's
honestly like compared to your typical
greens powder this is obviously
palatable the other look is purely
because of taste yeah yeah okay I can
get behind that I mean it's just easy
Nordine my goodness very it's really
easy compared to like so I've tried once
from my protein and frameworks that
they're flavored them it's like super
berry or blueberry or whatever they are
tropical
yes you could add it to like chocolate
way you wouldn't even know us oh nice
cool which you should also get chocolate
way just that it's the way to live your
life in an easy way
I think definitely when you starting
with a new supplement chocolates a
pretty safe one to go for but most
companies now pretty much everyone does
sample packs yeah so just get the 25
grams single serving sample of one of
everything and then you can go I like
this I don't like this I should write
that like on
you should make a poster that just says
buy the sample pack stick it to the
front of use of civilized so I've never
got a sample pack but I'd like I feel
like my days of experimenting with way
like that was when I was young in races
you know use way anybody yeah like I
have the audio but I've got a problem
now which is because I get the bulk I
usually get the largest increment of way
that I can every single flavor but the
new flavours coming out coming out at a
faster rate than how fast I can seem way
how many pros do you think you've had
over the past five years you've enjoyed
like really genuinely thought that's
nice is it is it less than 100 yeah
definitely that's the bit that you have
what every day mm-hmm one more after if
you want more after that bad boy so
though well I'm currently on the hunt
for a new brand of protein I want
something that actually tastes nice so
if you guys have any suggestions like
I'm happy to pay I feel like you're the
man with it with the answer yeah I don't
know why I think so protein works some
of this that's real good they got some
great flavor I don't to go for some
generic brand I won't like some giant
genetic supplement no nutrition or
something like yeah I don't get it like
it's just protein yeah I agree
it is it's such a transaction definitely
and I've said this is a protein works
despite the fact they support the
podcast the best protein I found at the
moment is bulk powders beef isolate does
it taste
chunky at all chocolate just pure
chocolate the best chocolate ever but
there's no there's not a single smidge
of day of dairy in it and it's isolate
so it's super thin my protein do a beef
a normal beef powder it's like you have
to punch it down yeah how much so like
median thick and that you can ride
maltodextrin in it's good I'll just give
you is it it's like something then is it
nicer than a normal way or is it nice
because you you're trying to take away
taste wise yeah it depends so I've
really developed a taste for it I
enjoyed the taste of that particular
right shaken out and the fact that I
don't get even the slightest amount of
my discomfort which I was getting really
bad from way to get bloating
yeah bloaty just uncomfortable then I
switched to a varying degrees of diet
whey isolate the dose still bad then
switched to my proteins beef still
wasn't too good because it was so thick
just gelatinous glob of like this
cylinder of just material that's you
know when you have to unblock it drain
you put mr. muscle drain and blocker
down you seen a bit of had just moved
that's what it was like and then this is
brilliantly so if you're buying flavored
things get chocolate is safe and now
that greens powder like if you if you if
you want to eat I'm one of these people
who always thinks all right there's not
that there's no reason why I shouldn't
just have a greens powder no it isn't
you know I haven't not had a greens
powder in as long as I can remember now
right well so you just have it playing
on a tone tropical protein works when
it's fine anything that's alright
half a glass of water totally fine to
our greens party no I've got one that
it's expired NASA threw it away
I think me stove but my protein veg
that was like garlic and mushroom soup
about ourselves and I've mix it with
Raven I've mixed it with leucine and
psyllium husk and then just drink it
down because it's so pungent you try and
make it concentrates than you black even
worse and so they they try and have it
with like a pint of water than you might
actually it's not diluted the flavor at
all it still tastes just as concentrated
Bernard it's got more stuff to drink
awful
Wow right so I've got quite a lot to get
through but that's there move it you
could always save some for next time if
you do one now okay we've got quite a
few suggested from I want to stick to
yours I'm not having I'm hearing you but
that's why everyone here is watching
because of you but well this is poor
Turner's poor not small he has said
whenever something comes out like an
event comes out and tickets at six
months in advance
whether or not you can go up by two
because then you've bought one and then
you can just invite someone later you
don't have to pick who it is you don't
have to arrange it just closer to the
time you come you are there
Browns coming to the tunnel but two
tickets differently going and it's like
that's a great tip I know loci employed
it myself previously in benefit from
Brian Cox took my mom brilliant like you
can always find someone to go with you
to a cool event as long as it's good
things
well yeah yeah if it was something
really weird that you really gonna have
to try and convince someone to come to
your eyes does anybody fancy going to
the new Dungeons & Dragons so if that's
the case then like that's a really
fundamental like you've got to
re-evaluate your friends like if there's
nothing that you can do or I'm a
painting workshop happening in the back
end of the town wall this week so we
have the monocle I think I'd go to both
of those but just out of intrigue I'll
probably say frail are very voyeuristic
for you is near okay right this one oh
my god so send to kindle extension for
Chrome on MacBook Wow
these you're getting so into Kindle
these days so I've started using my
Kindle egg white bait boy yeah so I love
my Kindle I don't like reading articles
on my phone because phone the way that I
use my phone is very skiddish
flicking around between apps I mean the
rhythm of whatsapp and Instagram and
stuff just it's a it's how I operate on
them not rub the deep reading laptop as
well it's just you don't be at my desk
standing or sitting or doing whatever
kind of not not to me so Kindle now is a
article reader as well previously my
solution to this was use Evernote Web
Clipper clip to ever no export as a HTML
file repurpose and export as a PDF then
use the center Kindle buddy
I was also arduous much but I just
wanted it cuz you need to have it so it
looks nice on Kindle so it needs to be
in PDF it needs to have converted it
needs to have stripped the formatting it
needs to have kept you know all of the
different stuff
whose just ugly real bad process and
then one day I just googled is there a
center Kindle there is a center Kindle
x10
for Chrome that you can search now it'll
be in the show notes below and you just
press one button previews the whole
thing makes it the perfect size allows
you to zoom in and out with the font
size that your preferences are on your
Kindle paperwhite you can edit before it
sends in browser you can edit the title
and the author of the article that
you're talking about in cases sometimes
it doesn't pull through the rug quite
the right metadata and it just sends it
perfectly formatted to your Kindle
instantly every Kindle device that
you've got how's that article as it does
it save it like in your library yeah as
a in the cloud every so it'll be on
Kindle on your phone Kindle on you
whatever man
II and so I'm as opposed to sending
stuff to pocket now pocket for me is low
grade [ __ ] pocket is like soap five
minute reads sub 10 minute reads but if
I've got meditations on Moloch
hour-and-a-half read is big monster of a
blog post I've wanted to do and I can
just read it like a book and you can
highlight passages that will save back
out in our man it's phenomenal I haven't
had I've learned something that changed
the way through my life that much in
ages sent Kindle for Chrome so right the
problem I always have with like because
you have Toby and pocket like all these
things to like delay the time you're
gonna read something what I've never
really had is a time when I would
definitely read it mmm-hmm but something
that I do is really very recently just
read a bit of my Kindle in the morning
because it means I don't have to use my
phone and my laptop or anything so if I
can take something from that and read it
then so I think quite a good solution to
that is either like attach it to a thing
that you do that I guess like you
haven't got a long commute or anything
so it doesn't apply for that but I find
morning when I'm getting up brushing
teeth making a tea or whatever is in the
first sort of 10 15 minutes
great time for just opening either
pocket ever know something like that
swiping down with two fingers from the
top over the iPhone and then it just
reads the article so it's like an
audiobook or just listening to an actual
audiobook in that time so I wonder
whether seriously while you're like
while you're waking up
yeah listen or something or if there's
any like dead time
if he waiting for food in the microwave
or something my lung that's something we
might know that I've done before we're
going back to an old on their butt
pocket which is a read later saving app
on mobile has a function where for maybe
about 60% of articles you can just press
the headphones at the bottom of it and
it'll just read an article that you've
saved they changed your voice which is a
shame I haven't done it in haven't used
it used to be a great voice novice this
weird American like digital sounding it
wasn't really accurate previously anyway
Johnny
well you'd uh which one to pick Ben and
Jerry's move for you it's just one of
those low calorie it is but so low
calorie ice creams are like all the Anna
penny at the mothers no sign of any work
matter to you guys cuz you'll just eat
the normalized feelings still not gain
weight but for people who are like are
in there in the halo top crew like halo
top compartment so here the top is
between 218 let's say for the calories a
tub move four is slightly higher sits
around six hundred seven an Academy the
tub it's way way more than a
proportional increase in taste for the
increase in calories okay like I mean
it's Ben Jerry's is it move for you
that's what Oreo what's the flavor so
that I think they only do like three or
four it's like a caramel one chocolate
one hang on so to move for you it's a
range yet I do okay so I get they're all
purple toes yeah so they have like some
Ben and Jerry's flavors are just like a
lower calorie version they used to do a
frozen yogurt like back in the day light
back in nineteen thousand ten and they
stopped doing that and they brought this
out now so her it really good how much
of a tub do you need to eat to be
satisfied because the problem I have
with halo top is all while good tell me
that it's only 350 calories per tub mate
yeah but for me to be satisfied because
it's mostly air I have to eat the whole
thing either/or thing so I probably
would still eat the whole thing that's a
big chunk of you calories for the day
not really since this motto is eat the
whole thing yeah Mike Huckabee that's
why I'm mister granola
I was gonna not eat the whole thing I
just get normal ice cream have a bit of
it but I just I just don't think that's
that's normal term have been juries that
1,200 yeah yeah so you're talking about
50% off yeah Al's on it and I don't
think so I'm not like an ice-cream
connoisseur but I don't think on a blind
taste test be able to it maybe maybe
normal Penn dairies is like way creamier
but that's close enough
yes Jamie is that is that rude like
Laura versus normal coke yeah I think I
could hear oh yeah so the later kind of
cokes at the brought the Pepsi Max yeah
yeah yeah so the other thing which is a
separate life hack is I it was just
related to this is I I'm far happier
buying a serving of something that I
know I can eat the whole thing off then
feel like I have to ration myself so if
I were the but if I were cook if I would
have want some biscuits and I have a
pack of a serving of three biscuits and
a packet universities taking the three
biscuits out of a packet and then
putting the packet away I get way more
enjoyment out of the of eating the whole
pack of three and a half or a portion of
the pack if it was a huge amount of
nutritional psychology and that isn't
that like and they look at people who
have the people who tend to be there
like natural weight gainers are the ones
that will eat everything that's on that
plate maybe from the way that we're
acculturated or socialized when we're
young tonight you've got to finish your
whole plate otherwise like this there's
that and there's also that like we
override our own satiety response
because we're like well there's my plate
got to finish it and yeah arbitrary
amount of food if you haven't served it
right if mums put this on your plate
there that's it that's the size of ones
estimate oh yeah and actually now
canteens no longer are allowed to
discriminate when that you know and they
look at it like big Dumon are can be an
extra bit of chips and they're not that
now we have to just give people standard
ocean and like yes I wash it just
because it's someone got upset someone
someone got upset it was all people suck
someone has green hair yeah I see you
got annoyed if you see this article
that's been shared around by
Douglas marine and some people recently
saying I'm a heterosexual woman who's
politically opposed to heterosexuality
please help so it's a politically
opposed to it so it's a woman happy
needy so it's a woman who was a
heterosexual woman who is sexually
attracted to men but hates of patriarchy
doesn't like the fact that a
heterosexual man objectified women so
she is now trying to find a bi-curious
man on Grindr who has woke politics but
will also [ __ ] it and this this all came
out recently that's fine you can do what
you like either one just gets turned
upside down here sounds like Hughes
needs like something better to do good
Roger yeah yeah like just like a hobby
or like a you know an interest that
isn't just finding something this pickup
I've I've tried to summarize your life
hack as allow the manufacturer to do
your portion control for you so yes I'm
really behind that like if all of my
food came in a packet I eat the whole
thing just John so happy about so you
like discrete value well that's the yeah
EMU isn't it
it's the fat kid in me two and a half
thousand calories with enough protein
okay I don't have ever seen you like eat
a meal and then see just a little bit
more off someone else's plate and now
I'm fine I accept so many other knives
to people when I was dieting where I
like we'd go out for a meal and I
thought I'd be served a portion up with
I'm gonna go my calories and they go why
don't you see half of it like I far
rather eat all of it and know where I am
then half of it yes like if I all of it
I'll be able to find the calories online
and then I'll know are there any
calories for you half isn't well did
have three integral does that you know
that you're gonna put that amount him
you can just put nought point five serve
I know but it's less fun isn't it
there'll be people who listen to this
you think I really are you agree with
that man then I just think
who that thing all of something is a
very satisfying way to just take
organize your day come to me right
Yussef there you go like I bet you have
a bit of the bag of granola don't you
oh yeah well as you've heard of me you
can't finish boxes of cereal why not
because no one's made it yet because gap
in the market is right what is it is it
your bag this is the no mo bag these are
incredible I mean it's looking a bit
tatty knocks I've had it for 10 years
but they are designed with MacBooks in
mind so you can slip your little pink
back book in there and it's got a
special pocket is you can probably see
that's lined with very much book
friendly stuff this has been all around
the world just absolutely great for
transporting you might pick around what
is funny please we tried condoms awesome
yeah and see your back contains a pink
mark book let's go make that sound oh
yeah it wasn't as you claimed the the
macbook friendly compartment Chris and I
just exchanged a glance of like we both
gave each other look they'll be able to
make it happen and we both just went
so did you understand I'd yeah well I
think this is what what I was confused
by was I feel like that's a very common
back but back backpack backpack feature
that was Wireless now it is maybe back
when you 10 years ago and when the Nommo
pioneered the you think you said to
Coleman made with MacBook in mind
mm-hmm I think that's a that's a big
claim made with MacBook in mind that's
there that's that stick is it yes or is
it a man actually one of our clients I
was buying a new one and I looked at the
photos they are it's Freddy as one of
our clients who's a model and he was
modeling the bag the money it's a
good-looking bagging events for forever
but I just don't believe so no so yeah
and the other thing the other thing as
well as you are with a man who has gone
for the absolute Ferrari of backpacks
here no oh yeah the belt for athletes
one tool oh no no tool is so I just have
a little tool oh yeah now I have a build
for athletes one oh God you very
CrossFit on alone well at so the reason
for that is have you seen what's
happened to the price of two laptops
laptop box yeah no no insane but their
neck they are unbelievably boring it was
60 quid
mmm-hmm now that same bag is over 200
quid Wow yeah and it broke the one I had
the zip point you can tell so what I
like about cool is when you see someone
walking through an airport with one arm
you lie
it's just someone sounds like you guys
trying to speak Arabic when you say cool
cool
how did you say how's it spelled Thu le
okay how would you pronounce that
well [ __ ] can't believe that there was
condoms in your bag and we would not
believe it it was it was Macbook condoms
cross on a stethoscope that's not all
the essentials I also really like how
your idea of a portable snack is pastry
well it was a double pack because you
often pull out like the plastic
pocket of a like a planet raisin will be
upon a race if I'd won earlier that big
the separate because he doesn't finish
all of the things right how do we both
immediately because it's like thousand
calories just yeah yeah I've I've
collected some of these over a little
while and some of them are real good but
they've been fully integrated into my
life that the novelty's worn off that's
that's that's when you know that they're
good because then stayed the course
citymapper mmm I think I know what that
is but [ __ ] hell so any big facility
survived without it without City muffler
yeah so it's essentially it's kinda like
Google Maps meets train line comm meet
the bus timetable you put your location
of where you are now and where you want
to go in and it will give you all of the
different options of how to get there
do you want to hail a cab do you want to
get a mobile bike line scooter thing do
you want to do a combination of walking
and tube walking and overground train do
you just want to walk the whole thing
and you just choose and then once you
press go on your chosen route especially
if you taking the tube it's linked in
with the tube timetable so tells you
what time what platform you need to go
on or you need to go north bouncer turn
right when you get to the thing and it
downloads it offline so that when you're
underground in the tube it will know
when you go and all you do is swipe
right when you've got to the next thing
it even knows the timing based on when
it thinks the tube would have arrived
and comes up on your phone saying you
probably need to get off now like when
it when it thinks you're at the next
stop then you get off and you keep up
that's not GPS based that's time-based
it says very clever up like in
it's nice having seen it grow over the
years like you've been have you been an
old you yeah so it used to be relatively
rudimentary and only have like one or
two cities and now it's just like
includes yeah Boober cycling but the
Barclays bike things walking estimates
like all the different methods and it
just like tells you like okay that's the
quickest that's the cheapest
here's how long that's this is how many
calories it will expand hair even tells
you how many calories you're like spend
by doing each route man its its owner
city map is it is there like a paid
version I'm just wondering I think
that's nods right
I think it must be ads-b enough mom
freemium freemium right Johnny got is me
this is a journaling thing for those
people who do journaling Trancas video
gardenias Randy the next day so there's
a a lot of journals do like daily wins
daily gratitude all that sort of thing
but something that I recently but it was
kind of suggested I try was journal one
thing that went badly in the day so Jen
let the worst thing that happened and
then try and flip it so like why is that
why is it a good thing that happened and
then what am I gonna do about it
tomorrow
and it's just constant evolution of you
take the whip take that the worst part
of your day and try and reframe it can
you give us some examples of things that
you've written I mean it's like it's so
it'll be all tiny propane very specific
things they're saying it was if you're
writing finishing that with this is good
because and then for show yourself to
come up with it because as always you
know I you know the chaco willing video
do no good I reload there's all there is
always something good I think there's
had a training session where I was under
slept and under eaten perfectly fine I
learned how I was able to get through a
session and a non-perfect sorta started
that yeah so like anything argument the
hired or something that went wrong like
injured my back like why is that good
well it's an opportunity to warm up
properly in future or etc so it's just
injured it's a good last year battalion
not everything's [ __ ] then then
shared something with me that um it's
ruined Jocko for me forever so you know
how Joker's instagrams like just photos
of it 4 a.m. 4 a.m. at this watch take
advantage and then show it's not that
it's a video of him and then the other
thing is a photo of the sweat on the
floor yeah aftermath it had a single
kettlebell it was a it was a video of
him doing chin-ups and training in his
garage
and you realize like it's just a guy in
like his 50s training and it's just not
the spectral form it's not that's all
impressive it's like you're like develop
phone like it's okay
but you imagine this like hulking mass
like squared your Navy SEAL like ripping
it up but actually it's like and it's
just rude late it's massive though
what's his name black guy David Oman's
Charlie it wasn't like Goggins yeah does
the podcast with it okay rapid-fire
round these are the suggestions by loose
bananas instead of packs for less waste
at various levels of ripeness
that's from Palma guren very clever so
you you buy a range of bananas ranging
from the most ripe and then like as the
week goes on she never got caught out
you have a look at convey about very
good page power lifts with not a fan of
this volume sorry tom drive 10 miles per
hour slower on the motorway so that
implies you are fuel economy you're
driving too fast in which light in which
case like obviously you might get a
ticket as a risk of that to be honest I
probably do need to do that because I
think like it just takes out the rushing
mindset well I think you you tend to get
a lot of car crashes yeah how do you
like you love a good good bump there
I'd love a good father so yeah II -
maybe just slow down a bit Nick Montez
hi Simon Robertson preload multiple bin
bags in the bin so in case of a split
bag the mess is contained bad windscreen
cover for your car in the winter costs
10 pounds saves 30 minutes better ROI
than a shoe it's followed up with horn
no car windscreen takes 30 minutes to
claim here take it's not 30 minutes of
active effort as well as always there's
always the break glass in case of
emergency you're having lukewarm water
and I know it might crack your
windscreen if you've got guests and wake
up so you know I actually saw people
opposite my house
fill up a freeze like run into the house
fill up a freezer bag with hot water run
out and like use it to drape it across
yes they're like draped and I know that
Yousef is is deploying some there he's
been sent here by people that follow the
propane Instagram if you have any life
hacks
put them in the show notes below sorry
put them in the comments below on
YouTube or just message them to me and
I'll feature them next time if they're
not [ __ ] mmm but if it's drive slower
you're not getting on it become so well
but one of these has to burn when our
ebook so the final two Pete column beard
apron - collects all the hair I imagine
that's like a device that you are
already seen it yes so it's like you
wear this necklace around the back of
your neck and it's a sheet of material
that then goes enough suction cups that
go on to the sea Mira Mira okay so if
someone comes in the bathroom it's easy
that's like what is easy there's a final
one good munzo link - if this then that
automatically save money every day I'd
like to see how you implement that Pete
is that could be quite good I think I
know which Pete that is Ronnie satis a
big fan of um automating you financier
something if you don't do that you're a
willy because bills don't need to be
paid manually though out direct just
direct debit everything it's like going
back to a manual car no like thinking I
wouldn't now I have to think about
manually changing the transmission of my
car as I change speed like why is that
ever a human wanted to do there are some
people some coaches I've worked with in
it that have billed me manually with an
invoice yeah [ __ ] just see I just avatar
I don't think so I think my favorite out
of them is the bananas bananas bananas
banana made it by Ranger boy bananas has
made it onto the life hacks thing all
the other ones
without school I made her an apple to a
banana personally having a really
overripe Apple as horrible as well is
that when it's soft when it's a bit
wrinkly really like thank you okay so my
next one is improve your email signature
so I had a terrible email signature it
was all that if this this message is for
the intended recipient if we scan our
viruses it's not a thing think a
environment before you print it mate who
the [ __ ] has no one if someone gets
infected with a virus because you've
sent it to them they're not gonna go
well you had that disclaimer on the
bottom that said voodoo events do all
they can to try and scan for viruses
please be as long as when people put on
YouTube no copyright infringement
intended
oh yeah maybe his DCMS are gonna really
be the worried about that then I'm gonna
crack down on you because you've stolen
a lot of Michael Jackson music so my
email signature went through and just
cut it down to the bare minimum which
also includes name so I'd never have to
say thanks Chris now which I kind of was
doing before because it was obviously
clunky that then create the email
signature on Gmail hyperlink the text so
you can create select the text so it
says Philly nightclubs at vu de New
Castle diggin you Castle links to our
website host of modern wisdom podcast
one of wisdom links then you can copy
and paste that cross into notes copy and
paste that out of notes into your email
signature section on iPhone and it will
retain the hyperlinks as well right and
all of the formatting you've also got
the quote below new like tis better to
have loved and lost than never mind that
was last week it to live life love now
live enough love yeah good memory I look
it's it's like it's my favorite type of
the paranoid people don't frape anymore
but putting a really a name quote that
like is like pseudo inspiration or the
you'd imagine on like some someone's
Instagram like with like texture like it
Jordan ah he doesn't
Putin's personal email address as the
truth will set you free I'm not kidding
[Music]
anyway my it's just on my Apple Mail way
when I select the email account on a
mail from it brings up the signature on
Arthur blob something exactly yeah
that's quite here the I have heard that
it was was like if you if you sell
anything
put the u.s. is nothing Lauer it's like
now put the URL in the signature and
then people buy it's just free traffic
it's the most free traffic the trouble
with that is we mail a lot of customers
and I don't want customers back in the
front end that's the word that's not
where's make that all the work I had to
do to segment and split them off in the
right place and then I email them right
Johnny Johnny Johnny so this is a bit of
a theme that I've been trying to do this
year so kind of like my new year thing
was to which is influence from a guy
called Sam Evans
he'll know your massive fans they are
marvelous but just the idea of so what
I've always Sorek Lee done is without
even my like self-improvement or habits
or anything like that this is the but I
think this is the best way to find life
hacks is I've typically had like the
weekends or I'll wake up late or do
things a bit differently or like I'll
modify my days a bit but I've tried as
much as possible to wake up at the same
time every day so like um like a minute
out since like the fifth of January over
go to bed same time every day train the
same days of the same week at the same
time eat at the same time so you just
create this like framework over your day
it is the same every time so you start
to feel hungry at the same time you
start to feel tired at the same time and
then my morning routine is exactly the
same and I've got it down to an hour so
I think I know you were talking about
this last time like if you know so I
know that by 8:00 a.m. I'm done
go downstairs coffee feed Dexter back a
walk stuck so go upstairs cold shower
start with by this time everything
everything in your life is so much
easier because like you want what sam
says is like you know fighting hormones
but you're not fighting like randomly
feeling hungry Italian because
way than yesterday not randomly feeling
tired at 9:30 boy you've got that
running so I pop that the life hack is
one rather than trying to do well I
think most people do is am i right now
is the time you're going to prove myself
I'm gonna pick this really complicated
thing and try and stick to it
pick like the most basic bit diversion
and do it perfectly for like 14 days and
then try and pick the little
optimization points what's an example of
that so the guy you interviewed the
efficiency is everything guy spoke about
like write out your morning routine for
example and then look for little ways
you can make it better
so rather than like I'm gonna wake up
and stretch and Journal and read and
exercise and have a brain check I pick
like three things or one thing that you
know you're gonna be able to do and
prove it to yourself for 14 days I'm
never gonna miss then not one thing in
when you just when you have that you can
spot like actually like I could add this
and that would make that I like a little
bit better or a little bit quicker I
like I'll brush my teeth then she'd
smell more so so to add to that then the
thing that this guy talked about he used
the example of what Henry Ford's first
public speech about manufacturing
process and that was my example so when
he gets undressed yeah my example don't
give it to him oh god okay
[ __ ] sorry Chris is an example
of where he rather than doing up his
shirt from top to bottom and then
putting his tie on it was put the shirt
buttons on from bottom to top and then
his hands were already in the same spot
to do the tie and although that sounds
like a silly thing when it's when it's
Henry Ford and that's like and then the
Ford Motor Company yeah that's why yeah
that's what you got and so the idea of
like batching your task so that you have
your tooth brush and floss in the shower
you wake up you turn the shower on you
go and boil the kettle you come back
clothes off in the shower you wash your
it's shampoo and that you've got the
ensure that they're so bus it so you
wash you body from top to bottom
rather than like lather up the lower
parts of your body and try and work up
and then you've got both cleaning to do
I think that the I know it's sound so
basically I really didn't say it cuz
like to say like just do the same thing
every day sounds so but it's better it's
actually very hard when you're
self-employed as well and there's no
yeah limits oh no it's not a framework
so I know my shower is ten minutes long
there's very specific reason why it's
something that's on progress of the
adding coal to the end of it but like I
know pretty much within a five minute
window when I'm starting work and so
that I know when I'll finish work yeah
and it just everything is is so much
easier and there'll be people who are
like yeah obviously mate but like how
many people lie in on the weekend
because they think that that's improving
their sleep when actually it almost
certainly isn't so just try that I think
that's really it really helped me the
slight is great so I think that
principle can apply to a lot of work as
well which is like and this is where
Gantt charts come in where if you're not
aware of what a Gantt chart is is where
you have multiple streams or strands of
a process all happening in parallel and
then you've got to see which ones are
bottlenecks by other ones so which one
is required before you can do the next
one which one's need to be started and
then left to run on their own and don't
require further input but you need to
wait for them and basically what can you
look at within a large project that you
can set all these dominoes off go away
and do something else rather than sit
and wait for that domino to fall and
then come back to it you'll find you can
compress quite a lot of tasks into it so
it's like go to a lift people come in
the lift you far then that's what the
beginning of you other things it's the
perfect way to put that you do not need
a Gantt chart to make this work you can
do it quite easily just off your own
back but perfect example of that is if
you're going to sit down and do a
morning routine and you have a coffee as
a part of your morning routine make the
coffee at the beginning and allow it to
cool throughout yeah yeah and it means
that the cooling is a it's a process
which has to occur you might as well
allow yourself to do other things was a
bet when you have coffee you probably
make your coffee before the shower so
the most frustrating part of my morning
routine at the moment is
tween waking up and like starting my the
first thing I do is I read there's the
eats like the lowest kind of effort
thing to do but I'm just so like even
though I'm getting like seven hours of
sleep seven hours sleep I'll wake up I'm
a bit drugs slow so but but this is the
thing that's kinda what I mean like what
I'm looking for now is what can I do to
kind of leverage on me away on it so
that's what I'm gonna have in my head
minute so this know this is why I bought
a 50-quid trampoline just put that at
the beginning what so you know rebound a
trampoline do you not I mean like a
small trampoline I know a small trunk
liner so it's small trampoline so much
in a small trampoline I am that but one
of those the reason is I know that when
I saw like you stir you mentioned here
for a walk first thing right don't
really want to do that because I do that
anyway with texture bar an hour or so
later don't really want to Train because
I feel like overall this thought about
doing like I I could do burpees or like
if I move it might might get my blood
flowing but like realistically
who is gonna wake up and do burpees no
one so you can't trampoline bounce you
get off a trampoline firstly it's way
harder than you think and way harder
than you think
secondly there's not really any physical
impact at all other than so right now
just to recap you more a trampoline yes
like like a if you imagine a big
trampoline it's a little smaller one yes
and you're going to that's gonna be your
thing
I am doing that bounce happy yeah okay
bounce so the biohackers handbook and
suggests that don't say not bouncing on
a trampoline it doesn't bring up that
specific surprisingly it doesn't
actually have any tips about that weight
does say is going upside down so
inversion so that might be worth trying
you could alternate you could do
trampoline one day be honest I'll be
well it for that so answer Robbie I
boots no no no no so it's you need to be
upside down with hands on
so you kick up on to a wall like he
would have used to have done in CrossFit
I struggle Chris to get my hands on that
chance of me getting into a handstand
tender so this is how you'll this is how
you'll get you dumb any confidence up so
you can do it but um so you're very
physically capable of it yes it's not
it's not just do a press it's just to go
into a handstand I can and that just
gets the blood down in your head that's
precisely what to do yeah and I were
exactly yeah a little bit yeah I did it
when I was 13 good night
yeah it's because first thing in the
morning you're adenosine receptors
aren't active that's why you don't need
caffeine within the first 90 minutes so
your adrenal system is what's active
that and what's the stress hormone
cortisol cortisol I accept what wakes
you up in the morning right
so adrenal system gets activated salt
lemon water and going upside down my god
midday about me nuts you're sorry you're
upside down just for fun yeah it's true
I just love being upside down so I'm
gonna start doing that do you prefer
being upside down to being right where
it is really meditative and a lot of a
lot of really advanced handstand errs
like become very like they they all
describe it as a very meditative
experience I think it's because like you
know the Zen things about balancing
stones or it's just that like you you're
totally focused on maintaining your line
and it's it does just like so feels like
it would be beneficial it just it's just
more shoulder load isn't it more like
Stabila there's a lot of lonely going
through your arms as well yes hard it's
like you know a head press it um so I've
put yours down as eat to sleep and train
at the same time I'd have it's in Peretz
yeah so like once you've got that like
once you're running and kind of doing
that consistently then looking for like
how can I improve this that's what you
have it's on so it's like might have a
viable product on yeah it's like so
before you're like how can I make my 3
our morning routine think like well why
don't I wake up at the same time you
here for five days and then start to
slowly add things in so just adding on
to that I didn't know that there's a
rationale behind it but I've always
found first coffee of the day decaf so
the coffee I have in the morning like
while I'm doing my morning routines
decaf I don't have
Cuffy until eight or nine I just feel
bad about what time you waking up tents
so 650 okay between 649 in from 651 I
love the window that that tight yeah
what's the window well you know how many
human Chris yeah
Yusef speaking of making these little
optimizations and you know do it in like
a social situation where you you might
have met people that when they introduce
themselves and they say their name and
they kind of mumble it or they say in a
weird way or like they've got a name
like Iona and their own or some Enya
know what like and so something I'd like
both of your advice on is when you're
doing a rectal exam on someone you're
the typical thing that people say is can
you bear down on my finger and most
people are like they don't understand
but then if you say squeeze my fingers
sometimes they'll they'll try and reach
around and try and squeeze your finger
so mike has resorted to saying imagine
you're mid Pugh and you have to quickly
nip it off in it a bit but I think
saying starting a sentence with imagine
it's too involved says that I so just
thinking while you were describing that
eventually I tried to bear down with my
bum as I do and I squeeze my glutes but
some people think that's flex if you
think it's relaxed like yeah cuz see on
a day would say push your ass all out
but that's as if you're gonna cover have
a poo isn't it and they only the other
one that I've heard one person used
terrible is imagine you're trying to
suck a straw through you bum that's
brilliant
there's a lot of glute activation going
on well that's right so but so one the
first one like bear down I think I think
hit thrust okay whereas when you said
nip off the poop I'm I know exactly what
he means no this is a classy because
squeeze my favorite remember like you
this is people who like if you say
squeeze my finger and they're not might
be a bit confused might be a bit
delirious
they were you've got to give them a
mouse they're also laid on this side on
a medical
examination bed with that pants around
their knees with a finger of them so you
can't be too watery solution then what's
the question because you initially say
if someone called I owner and now why is
this remembering you don't try and nip
off my fingers well they don't have to
be if you've got like I don't know what
what's the name that doesn't work well
with my name is or I am what I have to
do with the rectal exam because it's
that that's one of the optimizations
that's like something that you do alas
what do I do a lot like improving a
sentence yeah that optimizes it over
time
so looking at the things that you do and
maybe I'll just like try and stop but I
think Mike's got it yes of all those
things try and nip off the P its just
imagining you trying to imagine you
trying to stop yourself and pooing what
would you do Thanks that's why do they
want to do why do you undo that to see
if they can hold over rings yeah but
then sometimes you get people that you
like have you got any pain oh I've got
some pain in my chest see laughs like
you're just saying that and what that
means now is I'm going to do a series of
blood tests well I got my fellow ended
up can you feel your bum hole I'm not
really in you realize the impact of you
saying that it's like it's decision can
you definitely feel it is like a right
cut and then sometimes our share can't
but then yeah anyway if they knew the
consequences of saying I'm not sure if I
can feel my bumhole
a lot more people would say I can feel
my bomb exactly because there are people
that maybe it's just like someone asks
and do you have this signing up to one
of the very very long email trigger
sequences on Pro print Fitness Chrome
isn't it yeah that's the wrong button
you are 30 days they email if you opt in
that's it
obviously you can unsubscribe because if
gdpr of course okay but if you don't
subscribe I have a totally neutral
feeling towards someone meaning your
rectal exam on me
neutral feeling that's like no I think
just because I like to think I would
only get myself in that position if it
was needed
yeah I can't imagine it being this like
someone saying me go
it's like well that needs to happen well
the the I guess it's the good thing
maybe not this comes back to like luck
is it life hacks 101 or something why we
were saying would it improve or reduce
your enjoyment if the other party
enjoying pleasure from yeah because most
of the time like the person doing it
also isn't that's kind of having a great
time either vengeance is a on peep show
they ask each other ones like could you
could you have sex with me yeah if you
had to and he was like yeah as long as I
think you weren't enjoying it I could do
it he was like you could have sex with
me if you were raping me you couldn't of
like why is it mine Yeah right use a
book book I have Johnny mention a new
book yeah so Johnny mentioned the mouse
mouse I didn't like it because there's
people listening that don't know what's
happening okay that's true I'm just
saying words for the audio people so
mass is a iPhone case the is brilliant
it's very protective their marketing is
about throwing off buildings and all
that kind of stuff and it's a single
case you can't see door we've already
gone through it we've gone through it
well yeah because Johnny talked of like
doing things a bit so oh no so this is
the it's called a Toro similar to book
book just a basically a leather case
it's because I tried to just final
frontier only carry my phone around
never do cash and I got caught at Lee
barbers it's having a haircut the guy
was even telling me about the scumbag
who just did a runner and he said he was
gonna go to the cash machine he just
left and he Agent P absent and I'm like
ah terrible like I would never do that
and then at the end was like the right
ten pounds and I was like do you take
card no I haven't got it you haven't
even got card with me I've just got my
mouse and my phone so I can't withdraw
cash like on you don't have any cash and
I forgot to return the cash tip so I had
to get so you were the person yes tively
that he was talking I was very good
magnetic thing is you know the the
wallet that christen wouldn't let me
yeah forget about that I understand
luckily both perk does a bunch of things
protects your phone if you drop it can
you describe what it is for the people
that are listening there's a leather
book shaped case but it's front and back
right it's not a case yeah it's actually
a screen cover as well it is like it is
I've had people take the piss out of me
at work for being a dad because I make a
lot of dad jokes and I've got a very dad
the last one was very very Muslim the at
last from the very person a little
miniature sort of religious script oh
yeah it was very much the other great
thing is if you do a lot of videos or if
you I guess if you sit on trains and
watch Netflix or some things use the air
pods case or you water but if you want
to pay 250 pounds to tampons in your
ears
speaking of which I've lost my ipod pro
case oh just the case but not the but
boy like four hundred fifty quid for a
new on eight pounds now that could be
was expecting what could be worse how
much are the pods themselves dunno
seventy bucks cuz I don't know is it
cheaper to just buy a lefty part that's
not the way they're done they case right
let's do I'll do one more and then we'll
do a quick fire round um so okay right
this one this one's a real a real hack
so I flew Emirates a fair bit this
winter and on both the flight two and
the flight back from Dubai to Bali one
of my friends was on who's a girl is one
of these else Tessa's and she gave me a
hack of how to get unlimited free
internet on average is it to know one of
the oh-ho stuff and I'm going I'm gonna
give it and maybe have had sex with them
definitely I haven't had sex with her so
point when when you go on when you go on
Emirates
it'll come up and it'll say how do you
want like on earth whatever it's on
earth and then you get to choose if you
want unlimited instant messaging on 20
megabytes of data when you make about
today is like a trial thing and then
after that you've got to pay for however
much you have after that
choose to the 20 megabytes a day of
things you don't be restricted to just
the messaging mm-hmm
20 migrate today though and once you've
used it go back into your settings go to
the Wi-Fi network that you're on
pressing on air the little I then as you
see it there'll be a bunch of things
like a renew lease and a DC idea of
client ID that's just three numbers
change those to any other three numbers
and it will reset and you can just use
20 megabytes again and just keep going
that is unlimited free internet on ever
every Emirates flight for the rest of
time have we talked about that one when
I had that on hemorrhoids yes and you
went over somewhere that got you data
and then you're going to be charged 700
pounds 3700 funds if you fell it then
you fall asleep I fell asleep so no me a
message you didn't know me I let want it
to complain it all - yeah I just didn't
I just didn't put my phone in airplane
mode like where to sleep 40 minutes into
the flight open my phone text welcome to
on air Ukraine yeah and it was like
you're being hired
I pay homes a megabyte I pay a thousand
quid for a footage of that moment I
think three or five three five of you
realizing - calculators phone on two
legs going I just started mincing for
the rest of their like 12 mile flight
just something like right quick fire
round final so my final few okay isn't
me yes eat lean cheese protein hamper
elaborate so this is very again so you
survive adds grated cheese to things
except iPad calories eat lean I they
make it a standard cheese you can buy in
Tesco supply that it's very low calorie
like deep fat and cheese it's very hard
quite flavorless on the eat lean website
they do loads they do like a red
Leicester they do a smoked one then they
like loads of different cheeses and they
do a hamper and it just gives you all of
it to try like spreads dips everything
alright they've got a parmesan style one
yes I might even find ourself quite well
to parmesan so it was close to partners
right it's like when I order any was
thirty quid including delivery I've got
loads of cheese it's like a bit of a
sense from Johnny was about thirty
pounds of cheese it's a protein
supplement essentially okay and lower
fat very low fat oh wow
incredible that's great yeah so I like
per hundred grams Johnny generally tell
you what the macros are no GK no I'm
already on my way Chris okay yes I mean
I do care
yes it's a miss him is him is is lately
so a hundred Grimes to be honest a
hundred grams has 36 grams of protein
three grams of fat and two grams of
carbs calories 36 grams of protein I
just want to know what what's the matter
made up of like it's I mean when you eat
it you can tell like there's not much
fast enough like it's not you don't eat
it creamy delicious yeah like you we
didn't think Theron HEA close enough to
cheat you reset your own set point to
that like if you've been drinking red
milk for ages and then you try blue milk
the same as my beef isolate protein that
he just becomes normal yeah there's
opposed to the column that you have into
clocks I like for the carpet to get the
same calories from not even like low
calorie cheese you just having so much
bollocks to your calories but you said
you couldn't get this particular cheese
in the store you can get that standard
one initial so can I get if I find a
particular type of cheese in that hamper
that I like you can get it from the
website not from the different mushroom
yeah but can I get like it and I double
down on the red last oh that's right
okay yeah lovely right Seth how a glass
no hourglass hourglass so we've we've
been using various Pomodoro timer apps
recently and actually if the tasks that
you're doing in a Pomodoro is not
digital or you just don't want a digital
distraction having an analog timer is
brilliant
Yussef brought me and Johnny for
Christmas a one our beautiful brass and
glass and our bus I think for a brand
slice of Brussels last year would be big
would it be really be for shoots to [ __ ]
on tables in front brass and glass it
sounds like a trendy barbershop or
somewhere yes they also do tattoos like
a bar with bare-knuckle fighting but
it's all like hipster kind of it feels
it's their home and I imagine like a
dark bar when they do cocktails that
have steam coming up hmm anyone who's
out there that needs a name crew if
anyone steals that idea we rocky some
glasses do faster than you know what's
happening huh yes the hourglass unlock
hourglass was lovely and easy how did
you spend your New Year's Eve I didn't
have any kind of invites or any anything
thought that's interesting actually
cousin I I didn't have any invites to
anything either on New Year's Eve Johnny
what did you do on your New Year's Eve I
would say while a brewery what do you do
before that have the people that were
going along Prairie admirers that sounds
really nice do you think most like a
party see well I mean not really wasn't
it because I spoke to dab Gibson in the
gym earlier on I said what you're doing
tonight he said I'm going to Johnny's
for a parties I'm gonna party is house
so that's not then I text you and I said
hi mate
what are you doing tonight and you said
going Weiland brewery because that's
what I did and you came round to my
house on New Year's Eve just before no
and I said what you doing on New Year's
Eve you got a Chinese party anyone what
is this what party what is it what is it
so I can see why you're both upset
but it's not how I feel like you've been
given a slither of information from I
know that you went to why the audio
skips but I just feel I mean so wouldn't
it have been nice if we'd even just
early before even just an invite no I
just come round to it
for 60 minutes then go see you later is
that what twist Johnny's hourglass and
then V when it expires I would have just
liked to have been involved I mean what
did he what are using what not that but
what did you do I ended up going to work
why don't you invite me to work yeah I
knew Europe Weiland brewery I could have
gone to your house before Weiland
brewery oh I could have gone to work and
your work instead of one and becoming a
ticket I thought that is anyway what was
nice wasn't it we could fuzzing that
line in case you didn't know we've been
planning that for a little while
it felt planned it felt quite it's quite
nervous the end of it it was okay so our
hourglass where'd you get that hourglass
from okay the guilt org so what's really
really sad and I felt guilty by this was
my girlfriend for Christmas after I'd
ordered three hourglasses
was still coming in the post and one of
the presents are interruptions I think I
know what this is and it was a hourglass
but it wasn't as nice as the brass and
glass special one and she was like I
have been looking for bloody ages to
find a 20-minute timer so you can do a
Pomodoro in it and I found one
eventually after hours of looking it's
20 minutes so you can be focused Pro
yeah I think in our is a better amount
of time than 25 minutes to to pull the
Doris yeah because 25 minutes I was like
I've been caught up in my flow there's a
little bit
okay my final one do the washing up to
the pots and pans and utensils
immediately after curfew otherwise
against hard what I saw wet it's just so
easy it is 30 seconds now or two minutes
tomorrow that's it and you you waiting
for the food to cool or you scales or
whatever like you've put it away I just
clear it up tell you to like 30 seconds
with round job done and it is a great
it's a game-changer
so that's it for today thank you for
tuning in we are bonus round got some
quickfires know my facts 112 112 I'm
[ __ ] run out with them me the day
hooky now to spring them all over the
Sonicare toothbrush I said it okay yeah
yeah so Becca was waiting for the boxing
day sale for quite a long time to get us
both these Philips Sonicare toothbrushes
yeah so if you haven't got one or had
one I think I've got one yes right okay
so while I thought this is good fill it
I know I have a toothbrush after off
electronic Philips one that was quite
expensive say yes is about 70 quid it
was 70 quid in the sale
maybe yeah my buddy's a bit more yeah so
the great thing about it is you press a
button and then it goes 40 minutes and
it has a quadrant timer yeah so you do
like the bottom quarter and yeah and
then you go to the top quarter and the
case that you carried in has a USB
charger on the bottom of it it shipped
brilliant I'm not a really enthusiastic
about rush but none of this is
game-changing but I'm aware is this your
first venture into electric toothbrush
world so I had like a cheap [ __ ]
electric I think if you haven't had got
back got one or ever used one it's a
game show beginner so mine I was the
same I'd done I'd gone from complete
just manual manual yeah yeah it's like
true it's like using a manual cut and
then realizing well I don't eat it as I
do
yeah that's let's go alright I'm still
waiting to invest in a water flosser and
got wondering if you got one I've got
one but I'm I'm I'm wavering about being
using so it's nice don't they still
telling the flops and I'm using like the
sticks a little the drivers the bristles
brush things that they make me bleed
yeah they're very why are you not using
you I am beneath water flosser so you
have got one yeah it does make you feel
more fresh but I still feel like getting
in between the teeth still I'd love to
know what a dentist's opinion on there's
a friend take a shave it'll be listening
it's a Beretta number listen cuz he's
just had a kid and he's got nothing to
do except to just clean poo so David
Brendan please let us know not poo on
teeth the Internet is wait I'm David
anyway two gents thank you very much
pleasure we've got we've got some
leftover like facts 112 it's been like
four months since we did the last one so
it won't be as long to the next one I
promise don't forget to get a case of
bear bells all you need to do share the
episode tag me online and I'll choose
someone to do it propene fitness comm
will be linked in the show notes below
along with everything else that we've
gone through like share and subscribe
you know to do also if you follow the
links down there it will be supporting
the podcast and if anyone wants to come
to my New Year's party next year except
us except these two yeah more than
welcome that's not I'm not being serious
okay go by them
[Music]